[Music]
back now at 7 30 on cbs mornings with a
shot of reagan national airport and all
those airplanes you see there cannot fly
anywhere of course without pilots and
that's a problem because airlines are
struggling to find enough of them next
year they expect to have a shortage of
more than 12 000 pilots which has united
airlines launching a new program to
train the next generation including
promoting some other workers to fill
those vacancies errol barnett got a look
at the new program and we find him at
reagan national airport errol i think
this may be your opportunity to get your
wings
hey me you tony and everybody else good
morning and it may be hard to imagine
that this six-figure job with generous
benefits and unlimited travel perks has
become one of the most difficult
occupations to fill that was true even
before the pandemic so we went to my
american home state of arizona we
strapped in with the next generation of
pilots to see how one of the biggest
airlines in the country is taking a new
approach to fill the flight deck of the
future
lifting off at dawn in the sonoran
desert means catching this special
morning view in the valley of the sun it
felt like a joy ride
i love it i love flying
mother of two ricky foster is at the
helm learning the ropes with a flight
instructor a former flight attendant she
has been inspired to upgrade her wings
show me an excuse and i'll show you how
you can overcome that you know like
you're too old well
i'm 38. and there's someone in my class
that's a little older than me so we're
just starting now we're getting it done
foster is one of 59 students in the
inaugural classes of united airlines
aviate academy in goodyear arizona ceo
scott kirby says this is their effort to
combat the persistent staffing shortage
on the flight deck which has forced
route reductions
we've got over a hundred regional
aircraft that effectively aren't flying
because there's not enough pilots to fly
them by faa regulation pilots have to
retire at age 65 and by one estimate
almost half of them will within 15 years
couple that with the pandemic which
slowed the rate of new pilots taking to
the skies and it's almost impossible to
keep pace with all the open seats
one of the biggest sources for airlines
was the military the problem today is
they're not that many pilots in the
military there are a lot of drone pilots
so that doesn't really help terms of
being able to bring people in
united expects 50 percent of its pilots
to come from this program and half of
those will be women and people of color
the airline offers some scholarships and
priority to relatives of staff which
help form a university of san diego
football player aiden mack follow his
father's flight path they're
trying to cut down some of those
financial barriers with this academy and
it's really just opening the door for a
lot of people so i try and show them how
cool aviation is and that anybody can
actually do it
for foster who was originally from
jamaica this journey is also about how
her 17-year-old son and six-year-old
daughter see her
they got to come in and check out the
airplane and i have a picture of my son
sitting by my name
he was so proud in the picture like this
is my mom you know
future flyers bringing it home for the
family
now kirby acknowledges it will be a few
years before these students make their
way to the regional airlines and even
longer before they graduate to united
and its larger aircraft and for those of
you who live outside of big cities this
shortage does mean fewer options and
higher prices as all the major carriers
cut back service due to the shortage but
nate and everybody at the table you know
foster tells me that it really is the
pride she feels from her kids that is
the fuel that keeps her going and that's
why she wants everyone out there to
consider this as a potential career
awesome stuff errol thank you so much
what a great story i have to say earl i
like your placement we're sitting there
talking about united airlines they're
going hey
hey shout out to american i like
american airlines pbs news crew
yes that's right yeah we spread the
wealth thank you errol bravo bravo to
miss foster though and there's the
message that she's sending to her son
and to united airlines for taking on
this program it's nice well let's recap
the numbers overall 12 000 openings they
paid six figures each
time to line up i think that's a good
job yeah you could soon hear uh
this is your pilot tony decouple
speaking
oh my god i use the broadcast voice